我们这期嘉宾是位小康，我们请了位小康很长时间，你终于愿意出来聊了，对对对，之前不方便的公司。
对，这里也提一下，就是小康这一期的声音我们后面会应该会做一个后期的变声，所以大家听到的是AI版的小康。
这倒不是因为晋丽也之类的关系，主要是她不希望自己的声音未来被拿到网上然后让AI训练和模仿。
然后小康是我认识的移动互联网时代里面最懂组织和招聘的人，因为她应该是非常少有，甚至于是唯一的吧。
就是又深度参与过字节的组织建设，也同时深度参与过美团组织建设的人。
你是17到哪年的？
我是17到2012月份在字节，然后2012月份到26年1月份在美团。
你在字节是招聘负责人，然后美团也是招聘负责人，后来又做了AI产品经理。
然后我记得2017到2020年，应该正好是抖音最快增长那几年吧。
是的，那时候是16年初的，到17年年底的时候开始搞国际化，出来大家都知道了。
对，然后2026是美团大概一个什么阶段？
其实从21年到26年是中国移动互联网还在增长，但是从下滑，
所以是体现出来各公司组织能力建设的时候，就是到底什么水平。
当然对美团的组织内达有很多的真一样，
但是在我看来，在中国互联网圈懂零售怎么做的，只有美团和拼多多。
而你跟字节懂得其实广告怎么做。
明售是一个苦祸，那么很明显就是在过去的这十几年里面，
美团很好的把这个苦祸的基本工会联好。
对，这两个公司的业务模式其实非常不一样，
所以它的组织建设应该对应的也是很不一样的。
是，就是你刚去的时候可能会觉得很多方面看起来是反的操作的，
不管是星球、季孝的那些政策、照片的那些理念等等的。
但实际上你如果你跑跟问到你看的话，
其实两边的文化和创始人的一些底层的观念都是一样的。
只不过说美团因为是零售加科技，
我管这个叫长周期、长业务链条、低贸率，
然后我管自己的业务叫短周期、短链条、高贸率。
他们俩播的团队分别在研究到底什么样的组织是这样的业务。
对，你刚才讲到人和组织的问题，我们可以分别来聊聊，
因为我觉得你这个样本真的太稀缺了，
能这么深度的内部视角去看两个，
我觉得是过去十年最有代表性的公司。
所以你怎么看，我们先从人开始聊起吧，
以后可以代表组织，你怎么看张一鸣跟王星，
就他们为代表的一些创神的特性吗？
我不太方便去聊两位大佬，
也没有资格去评价两位大佬，
只能聊聊我看到的一些优秀创业者的特性。
我觉得第一个就是他们都属于学习能力很强，
且好奇心很重的人，
就是有些人是学习能力强，
但好奇心不重，
他就对那个东西没有探索的意义，
他只是可能被应事教育摧残，
然后第二个点是依稿都很小，
而依稿这个词有很多的定义，
在我心中理解的是这个人又很自信，
又很谦虚，
就是他一方面在各种各样的挫折，
或者各种各样的事情上，
都能够不被打倒，
且坚持自己的判断。
另外一方面，
他能真正听得进去别人的意见，
且知道自己不知道是吗？
对，我在想，
我们挨个词都可以拆解一下，
你刚才讲的第一个是学习能力强，
而且还得有好奇心，
这个学习能力强，
你觉得这类的人大概体现在什么方面呢？
就是我们正常看见的血板，
学习东西很快，
但是学习能力我用于过一个门槛就好，
就是如果说你想成为一个企业家，
他并不是说要成为像那个。
奥赛金牌那样的智商，
比如贝索斯在资本里面其实分享过，
贝索斯其实在读书的时候，
他学的是物理学，
布林斯顿，
我看过他那个讲的，
对对对，
就是他搞一个偏为方程的这个题目，
跟一个同学搞了三小时，
没搞定，
然后去问另外一个朋友，
给人家看了一眼，
告诉他答案。
我觉得这个是不是来自于，
他们对于一些底层规律，
或者甚至于像马斯克那种，
低性原理的一些把握，
就他可以快速的看到一个问题，
然后抓到那个本质，
然后通过各种类比，
等等的方法。
我认为你说的那个其实还需要结合好奇心，
如果他没有好奇心，
他只是学习能力强的话，
他可能就随便搞一搞就好了，
遇到个东西，
他们才能搞清楚，
为什么这样，
为什么不念，
以及为什么一定要这样，
为什么不可以那样，
可以把刚才的智商那个事情再讲一下，
我认为可能说，
比如说做个解释员的公司，
纯致力水平，
在酒吧屋里面，
要当千百分之一，
就够用了，
因为我们不是搞物理学，
我们不需要搞很难的题目，
我们只是把某个行业，
到底怎么搞不搞清楚。
对，我觉得可能甚至都不用，
只是这十年的，
美元资本的投资，
让大家觉得说，
你背景一定要特别好，
但我相信，
如果你真的把，
比如说A股上市公司利的创神，
背景扒出来，
可能,
但跟时代有关系，
可能很多都没上过大学生去，
我觉得，
对，就是其实是在各个行业里面，
都有一些很优秀的人，
可能不用百分之一，
因为,
能上酒吧屋的，
已经是同年人里面的百分之一了，
在酒吧屋里面再排千百分之一的，
那基本上已经是属于万里调一了，
可能千里调一，
说不定也是够用的，
就,
第一个事情，
其实是纯致力水平，
到这个水平里面够用的，
第二个事情，
其实是，
你要跟上一个行业的大郎朝，
就是新哥在21年那时候，
内部做归次分享，
那个话可能，
有些人觉得他说的是套话，
但是我当时是非常非常理解这个事情的，
大概的意思就是，
我们要清晰地认识到，
我们只是时代浪潮的一个，
浪上老水花，
就是因为有这个浪，
所以我们才起来了，
这是,
大佬们对这个事情，
很清晰地认识，
然后,
为什么说到依旧呢，就是，
如果你赶上那个好时代，
如果你的智商，
可能足够用搞清楚一个行业，
那么剩下的事情就是，
坚持搞下去，
很自信，
然后,
同时又能听得去别人的意见，
知道自己，
什么地方不行，
知道什么地方自错了，
只要运气别是特别特别差，
你基本上做非凡事业，
是问题不大。
对,
那你看，
就是依旧跟自信有时候，
比较容易混对吧，
因为如果他不是很自信，
或者说，
不是,
至少有一点依旧，
我自信方面的依旧的话，
他也不会出外创业，
他也不会觉得说，
我能当个好创始人，
或者我能做一个工作公司，
但同时，
他确实又不能依旧太大，
他就听不进去别人的意见，
我是觉得，
是不是因为，
最终其实是要，
比较理性啊，
就是他是很理性的觉得，
我确实，
某些方面能力很强，
所以我能做成什么事情，
然后又很理性的觉得说，
某个人他讲的，
这个逻辑跟论据，
等等都是合理的，
所以我应该听他的。
对,
我认为有一些是理性，
有一些是实事求是，
有一些是，
就是他可能经历过，
很多很多的挫折，
或者各种的事情，
然后他能够重新站起来，
他的一些东西，
是有信心和自信的，
就是打不到他，
同时,
他又知道自己，
可能不知道什么，
又知道自己，
可能说，
哪一方面做得不好，
哪一方面不是他的强项，
所以他听得进去，
就有些人，
虽然是实事求是的，
但他其实听不进去，
或者要面子，
或者出于这不断的原因。
对,
所以我们看很多，
非常成功的投资人，
都讲说他喜欢投，
经历过挫折的创始，
就是你要把你这个人，
成为打磨打磨。
对,
因为创业的过程中，
尤其是在大赛道庆创业的时候，
一定会经历到，
非常激烈的竞争，
中间肯定有很多的挫折，
甚至是可能被对手坑，
或者被下属坑，
注定不会一翻分，
如他之前没有经历过，
那其实，
一个失误，
可能就是有完了。
OK,
这是第二个，
依购不能太大，
后面还有吗，
别的,
因为他自己，
应该有很强的动力，
这个动机，
可能什么样都可以，
他可能是，
想让世界变得更好一点，
可能是想多着点钱，
可能是想，
成就一个什么样的事情，
够如此的可能，
各种各样的情况，
但是他这个动机，
一定要，
足够足够的强，
强到他能够，
经历过各种各样的挫折，
然后跟一个男的事情之后，
他依然愿意，
坚持我要搞。
很多人在讲说，
大家应该去，
不管是招人，
还是投人，
要投那个，
其他挺条件不好的人，
就是穷苦家庭更有动力，
但实际上，
好像张宁我不确定，
但肯定不缺钱，
对吧,
那王欣应该是家里非常有钱的。
对，这个，
最起码，
可能他们跟特别穷没关系，
而且,
就是,
物质上的苦，
是一种苦，
但,
创业者，
其实经历的更多上，
精神上的苦，
就这个东西特别难搞，
同行们都没搞定，
或者说，
最得力的下河，
被人挖走了，
或者可能说，
这个,
对手发个外头无人来搞了，
所以其实跟那个，
物上的苦，
没什么大关系。
这是第三个点，
动力,
第四个呢？
第四个我认为是，
经历,
就是,
对,
创业确实需要高精力人群。
我忘了，
应该是陈伟说的吧，
说都是雷总，
应该基本上不怎么运动，
睡得也特别的少，
依然可以保持非常旺盛的经历，
开一点点的会。
还有吗？
前面那四个点，
其实他个人层面的，
还有一个点，
我认为是，
对这个公司那边连最重要的事情，
就是,
能不能够把这个组织整个给建好？
靠单个人肯定是不行吗？
那正好就聊到组织这块，
你觉得，
就我们刚才讲，
这两个公司的业务模式，
其实很不一样，
对吧,
那就造就了，
他们的组织，
应该也非常不一样。
组织是一个特别大的问题，
包括行业内，
包括学术界，
其实都没有一个，
特别公认的定义，
就是当我们聊组织，
都得聊什么，
可能上一代阿里，
讲的是六卖神剑，
讲的是那个政委体系，
讯息讲的是那个杨三角，
杨三角是，
一位教授，
跟腾讯一起共创出来的，
大概的意思就是，
我们讨论组织的时候，
其实讨论的是，
员工是否具备相关的能力，
就是我们是否找了，
还不做的人，
第二个就是，
员工越面越易，
就包括文化，
包括公司的整个组织动机，
包括可能和组织的，
目标怎么可能，
跟员工那些医院，
交到一块去，
第三个就是说，
容不容易，
就是,
公司有没有提供相关的机制，
能够支持好员工，
大家一起来为这个事情拿奋斗，
这是腾讯那一套，
这一代的话，
其实字节跟美团，
内部有很多的，
对于组织如何建设的，
思考跟实践，
但其实没有对外公开讲过，
也没有说，
黎明或者是，
黄兴总结出来，
这就是我们公司的管理，
所以只能说，
根据我自己的一些，
观察和一些事件，
我给一些我自己的看法，
首先我认为，
我会把组织拆成两块，
在组织建设的工作，
我认为这两块是，
根据公司和园队，
最大时间经历的事情，
一块就是，
人怎么把它很好的运转起来，
人的话，
好像没有很多那种方法，
我一般会把它，
分为两块事情，
第一块就是按照一个，
人的流程来说的话，
就是,
选,用,
预,
立,
太,
如何选出来好人，
然后如何把它用好，
如何培养它，
如何激励它，
如何投赖它，
按照HR的一些模块来说，
可能是招聘，
文化,
新仇,
迹效，等等，
然后第二大块，
是业务和人，
怎么结合起来运转，
略偏业务管理和项目管理，
就是,
如何定出来业务目标，
如何把业务目标，
拆掉到每个人身上去，
然后如何大家能够形成合力，
如何识别出来，
哪个业务做得好，
做得不好，
以及如何激励，
和迭代它们，
然后这是另外一块事情，
字卷用的是OK，
然后还学了一些，
很多其他的一个公司的一些做法，
美团基本上学的是亚马逊，
搞运营计划给一套体系，
那你觉得这套适合创业公司吗？
创公司可能本身一开始的目标，
就比较简单了，
它有必要拆得很细，
说每个人就搞这一块东西，
它可能不是拆得很细，
而是说，
然后就它们三个人干活，
然后你会发现，
你理解的，
跟另外两个人理解的，
可能不是一个东西，
所以就是，
字卷为什么搞公开的OK，
然后一定要，
比较长时间去把OK，
这其实还是有必要的，
然后第二个事情就是，
哪怕就是说，
我们节奏非常的快，
我觉得可能还是最起码，
比如说，
你周围单位，
或者一月围单位，
我们及时对一对，
可能未来几周，
滚动我们的计划，
然后且保证，
我们的三个人，
或者我们的十个人，
理解的是同一个事情，
无论如果十个人的话，
最少应该会搞错，
10%以上的信息。
对，我想起来，
之前,
我忘了什么场景，
反正有个问题就是，
你公司你比如十个人，
你问每个人，
你们公司在做什么事情，
目标是什么，
可能每个人说的都不一样，
对，没错，
然后如果说每个人说，
这周我们到底要做成什么样的，
那好像一个十个人，
回答也是不一样的，
这个就是要不断地对齐，
对吧，其实就是，
尤其是自杀而下的，
每天要去不断的重复，
就这样的东西，
如果短片快的也有，
OKR可能是一个好的形式，
就是把OKR对清楚，
然后一层地拆下去，
然后如果是，
练条的，比如说今天很多，
AI加传的往来改造的，
那可能线上一下设计的更多，
我建议大家去参考一下，
亚马逊和美团在搞的运营计划，
就这个会搞得更为科学一些，
可能说这个，
几十个人，几百个人，
甚至几千个人，几万个人，
我们怎么去配合协作，
还是非常有用，
可能看起来，
我们每个月需要花几个小时去讨论，
但起码能帮大家省百分之十的时间，
所以就是第二块事情也很大，
对于第一块事情的话，
就是人这一块很具体的事情，
我认为，
应该百分之八九十的时间，
花在招聘上，
我们可以一会再讲招聘，
我们先把其他几个好几个模块讲，
比如说，
第一个是文化，
文化是一个公司，
非常非常重的及时，
但不需要花很多的时间，
文化的词有点重，
字节会把这东西叫字节犯，
美团把这东西叫领导的原则，
说白了就是，
到底我们怎么干活，
怎么做事，
然后你会发现，
所有头部公司的文化，
不管是像字节这样的，
还是像沃尔玛这样的，
基本都是类似的，
字节讲坦诚清晰，
美团讲敢于说真话，
勇于听丑话，
美团讲追求卓越，
字节讲追求机智，
然后你去看看沃尔玛，
或者看看宝节，
他的文化基本上是差不多的，
因为能够做成事情，
所需要的科学的方法，
都是类似的，
但怎么保证大家是，
比较坦诚清晰的，
怎么保证大家是实事求是的，
那其实原则就很简单，
你们那十几个，
二十个核心的人，
是这么干活就行了，
你们公司几十个人的时候，
你们几个创始人是那样做的，
然后反对不实事求是的，
反对不追求机智的，
你们公司几百个人的时候，
那十几二十个人是那样做的，
那像同学们，
兄弟们就会自然跟着学了，
所以文化这个事情在，
现在这个阶段很重要，
但最重要的是，
他们以身作者，
并且能够站出来说，
我们反对一些什么样的事情，
是不是在一开始的时候，
其实,
我觉得对于创意工资链，
它都不一定能总结出来这些东西，
但它就是一个前一幕化的，
大家做事的，
和为人的一种方式，
对，就是能创意成功的那批人，
他们基本上就是这样，
科学的方式做事情，
所以就是，
他们把自己怎么做的展示出来，
然后把反对怎么做的讲清楚，
完事了，
然后第二块，
可能是，
星筹计较的一些体系，
星筹跟计较们分开说，
到底给多少钱，
我们一块大招聘的时候再讲，
然后,
计较这个事情，
在大公司，
可能有什么360评估，
可能有什么一层层的review，
判断清楚谁好谁不好，
然后再想清楚，
这个人是给三个月，
那个人给八个月，
那个人给两个月，
以及为什么，
创业公司不需要想这些东西，
首先,
创业公司老板，
或者那几个核心的合伙人，
应该能够看到最一线的人，
他们就需要，
能够很快地判断清楚，
谁干得好谁干得不好，
该给多少钱，
如果他判断不清楚，
这公司不能看，
就是,
如果你要希望大厂那样，
我们做计较，
然后搞个一个月，
两个月，
然后第二个事情是，
如果一个发展的，
稍微的一项点的创业公司，
它增长是比较快的，
所以这个时候，
机力多一点，少一点，
没有那么大影响，
就咱公司今年这个，
估值发了5倍，
或者发了10倍，
它可能是从100万的年薪，
变成了300万、400万，
我是变成了480万，
它是变成了320万，
这无所谓的，
就算有些不公平，
第一，这是背后背的嘛，
第二就是，
大家都涨了很多，
就有无所谓的，
它发了10倍那种鸟，
我发了12个月那种鸟，
也无所谓的，
就是,
即效这种东西，
在现在这个阶段，
没有那么重要，
当可能公司已经很大了，
你们几个人，
一眼看不到下面了，
公司增长可能也慢慢变化，
然后需要变得更科学，
更公平的时候，
你才需要这个东西，
现在这个阶段，
应该是先拿速度，
至于还有直机体系，
因为我看有些创业公司，
已经在搞直机体系，
搞精神体系，
我可能认知不够啊，
我自己看过来，
我是觉得，
没有必要搞这个东西的，
就直机体系，精神体系，
这个东西，
本质上，
其实为了告诉大家，
可能说，
我们这个，
每个阶段的同事，
应该长什么样子，
我们应该向什么方向去努力，
这首先，
我们现在AI这个阶段，
发展很快，
到底该长什么样子，
我相信，
没几个人能讲得出来，
全球也没几个人讲得出来，
其实搞这个东西，
其实花很多的时间，
并且会导致员工，
奔着这个方向去做工，
为了晋升，
为了那个标准，
然后去做一些业绩，
做一些成绩出来，
我还要给写这个材料，
然后还参与评审，
纯浪费时间，
有那个时间，
我觉得好好搞搞业务就好了，
这是HR几个模块，
文化，技校，
OD,
还有一个模块生的培训，
每谈跟字节都很重视，
培养人，
但是我们都有个最基础的理念，
人是培养不出来的，
为什么？
人都是打完了之后，
淘汰出来，
筛选出来的，
OK,
每谈有个721理念，
大概的意思就是，
人的成长，
70%靠打仗，
20%靠跟一些好的，
前辈,
或者优秀的人去学习，
10%靠公司组织的培训，
培养,
还是能起百分之十的作用的，
最重要的事情，
其实是给大家战场，
给大家战场，
大家自己长起来了，
尤其是像今天，
跟一些工作十几年的人，
跟工作三五年的人，
其实在，
对AI这个时代，
很多东西，
应该怎么做的理解，
可能大致差不多的，
那给战场，
好的人就自动发出来，
这是这几个模块，
大概的事情，
然后我们再回到，
可能说最终的模块，
最终的模块就是招聘，
首先把招聘要拆环节，
我会把招聘拆为，
以下几个环节，
第一个环节是，
想清楚需求，
到底是怎么样的，
第二个环节是说，
OK，我想清楚需求的时候，
我得找供给，
就这些好的人在呢，
第三个环节，
才是判断，
就是我通过，
毕师，面试，
背料的各种方式，
搞清楚，
谁好谁不好，
第四个环节是谈判，
谈判包括谈钱，
我能不能给你，
第六个环节，
其实才是数值跟进啊，
这样的事情，
我发现呢，
就是很多，
创意者，
或者很多的中高层，
其实在后面面试，
这样的事情，
花了很多的时间，
但前面花的时间不够，
但其实是反过来的，
其实应该在，
想清楚需求，
然后找供给这个事情啊，
花掉你百分之五六十，
七八十的时间，
我为什么这么讲呢，
就是,
首先,
在我们现在这个阶段，
彻底想清楚需求，
很难,
但是我们有个悖论，
悖论就是，
你需要用人的时候，
给三个月之后，
或者四个月之后，
才有那个好的人进来，
所以你就应该每隔一段时间，
可能说一个月，
或者可能长一点短一点，
你就反复去想，
想什么呢，
想三个事情，
就是我的业务问题，
对我需要，
什么样的人，
来多少个，
什么时候，
然后想清楚说，
你的招手提前储备，
提前储备提前见，
甚至可能把他提前招进来，
但是,
大部分同学可能说，
我遇到业务问题了，
我才想着去招人，
这个是不对的，
神仙也解决不了你这个问题，
你一定是提前养好，
提前想好，
让一下提前帮你建案，
那第二个事情是扩控级，
搞定供给是整个招聘工作，
乃至整个公司建设，
最最最最最重要的事情，
没有之一，
直接决定了，
组织能建成什么样子，
以及能不能打赢，
它分为三块，
第一,
什么是好供给，
第二,
我需要什么样的好供给，
第三,
我怎么扩，
怎么搞定这些供给？
你的供给就是人，
合适你业务需求的好人，
首先你在市场有个判断，
比如说可能说你搞多模方向的，
或者说你可能搞一片硬件方向的，
那你能排一排整个市场，
都有哪一公司在做这一块的事情，
他们分别做得好还是不好，
然后这些公司里面大概有多少个好事，
然后你才能对你要招什么样的人，
有个大概的概念，
而且你还得认清楚现实就是，
我这个事情到底需要什么水平的好手，
有可能我并不需要那个大厂里面，
或者自治快方向，
前百分之五千百分之三的人，
有可能是在当下这个阶段，
中上的人可能就做够用了，
就是你得对整个市场的供给，
以及结果我的需求想清楚，
我到底要从供给里面挖一圈，
什么样的人出来？
但我在想，
你刚才提到一个点，
你说人的成长其实打仗打出来的，
那我要招这个人，
我是应该招一个他已经打出来的人，
还是招一个更猪腻的人，
如果是招更猪腻的人，
我怎么样能够判断他能不能打出来？
对，这个其实就是讨论业务需求的事情了，
就是,
如果你要面临的竞争，
比如说假定你现在在做一个AI电视上下玩的事情，
那信息下的供应链已经很成熟了，
如果你能招到一个，
这个方向很熟的懂供应链的好手，
然后快速地帮你把所有资源都给你配好，
那最理想不过的，
但可能你打的是一个很全新的东西，
比如说AI似的搜索怎么做，
可能新手跟老手有差距，
但没那么大，
那你看你经历这些公司，
你觉得能打出来的人的特点是什么，
他们具备的什么技术素质跟共性吗？
基本上跟创始人的要求其实是一样的，
只不过说他们可能是一个弱厚的创始人，
比如说我们想把算法这种工作可能搞得特别好，
那可能需要智商特别特别好，
但比如说，
我们可能直接想把后端搞好，
或者想把前端搞好，
或者想把安卓RS搞好，
或者想把真郎搞好，
那我认为就八五里面，
千百分之五千百分之十水平的智商已经足够用了，
然后这个人依靠得小一点，
再勤奋努力一点，
经历好一点，
但你比如说自己的每条里面都是这样的人，
那最后什么决定了，
谁能跑出来谁跑不出来，
如果在一两百万年薪以内，
我们基本上，
只要是之前我们聊的这四五个点，
没有什么短板，
有一两个成本就已经足够了，
如果是一两百万年薪以上，
拉开差距的主要就是两点，
第一个是他的动机，
就是两三百万年薪以上的人，
他会遇到完全不一样的挑战，
遇到更多的挫折，
不管是技术的挑战，
还是说其实可能遭受很多人的误解，
或者可能是对手搞你，
除此类各种各样的事情，
钱又基本上够用了，
就是这两百万跟这四百万，
对他全身莫致上提升，
没有什么特别的差距，
这个时候能让这个人把一个业务坚持搞下去，
主要是动机，
然后第二个点就是精力要好，
就是聪明成怒，
两百万跟四百万那样，
我聪明成怒差距一般不会特别大，
选择我觉得也是，
就是他在一个公司里面，
他选择到哪个部门工作，
敢不敢选择一个新业务，
这其实也是一种选择跟风险，
对，如果就AI这个事情，
我认为选择的原因会跟动机帮他一起多一些，
不管是说他因为爱一个事情，
还有他想做一些更纯粹的事情，
还有他可能想多挣钱，
对，因为有的人，
比如说我现在仍然可以去投调工作，
对自己来讲，
当然是一个有价值的，
也是一个搞回报的，
对，挣个三百万，
依然可以挣到的事情，
就是有一些人依然可以选择，
在上一代的一些产品，
技术框架里边去搞算法，
或者是搞一些其他的工作，
但有少数人选择了来搞AI，
对，所以在读东西之后，
真的是跟选择很相关，
但选择背后就是这个人的性格，
他的成长环境等等，对吧，
比如过去几年，
你选择去字节的，
选择去了字节豆包的，
还是选择去了那些AI应用公司的，
还是选择去了那几家大冒险公司的，
回报可能都非常不一样，
AI直播就这么快，
可能就是两三年的时间，
对，两三年十倍，
甚至一百倍的回报差距，
是，而且也有的人在中间，
可能就走掉了，
是的,
对，我相信，
什么minimax制谱等等，
中间理智的人一定非常多的，
对，去了minimax，去了制谱，
又回大厂的人挺多的，
对，但这个最后，
我们也很难纯粹用，
财务的角度来衡量这个回报了，
但我还在想，
如果他是打仗打出来的话，
那是不是最理性的选择，
就是我招一批人，
然后就把他们放到战场去打，
然后打出来的就留下，
没打出来就淘汰掉？
首先不是，
首先我们组织是服务幼学的，
不是服务淘汰学的，
应该是根据我们的幼通点，
我们组一批，
能够把这个事情做成概率最大的同学，
这是首先的事情，
其次呢，
就是创业公司一般自然是不宠配的，
一般前几年没有资格说，
这个我搞一批人，
过来这个淘汰，
只能说，
一方面我们需要，
尽管能找到，
能马上帮我们解决幼通点，
然后又好的人，
这是最理想不过的，
其次呢，
我们比较限时，
基本上可能说，
逮得一个差不多好的，
我们可以先用钱，
这是个节奏把控的问题，
就是为什么，
其实我看好90后，
或者95后的创业者，
因为他们这圈子打过一段时间，
他们很快搞起这样一个团内，
没什么别的原因，
就是他们这些创业，
这些招过，
或者之前有前下属，
或者是有同学朋友，
那这里面，
很多时候，
大家还要考虑一个成长性，
创业公司可能，
有今天我遇到一个这个问题，
我能找一个，
可能还不错人把他解决掉，
但是我如果正常，
发展的话，
我可能明年，
后年,
也许甚至于转型了，
或者也许是，
面对的问题，
是今天的十倍的难度，
但我现在招这个人呢，
他可能是个属手，
他不一定有这个成长性，
他就是，
会有各种各样的问题，
如果你确定，
你可能短期之内，
找不到那个高钱的人，
这个需要你自己对，
组织对业务进来判断，
可以把先把那个属手先招进来，
招进来之后，
我能该给人家的给到，
过一两年，
可能这个属手，
根本上业务节奏了，
那公司内，
总有一些可能，
没那么难度大的事情，
可以让他去做，
如果这人文化没问题的话，
然后就算可能说，
这个人完完全全，
根本上工资节奏了，
那就好就好散，
把该给人家，
继续还给人家，
完事儿，
我们前面讲的是，
供给的前两块，
一，搞清楚市场上，
我们是好供给，
二，我需要什么供给，
第三块，
扩供给这个事情，
最难最难的，
首先你可能搞得搞清楚，
整个市场的，
好人在哪，
其实我还得处打上他们，
处打这个时候，
就只能各演身同了，
就是,
你要可能尽可能，
能把周围，
所有的资源都用起来，
你自己有没有足够的圈子，
可能在社媒上，
有没有足够的影响力，
然后或者亲朋好友们，
答应没帮你，
这是最最主要的事情，
因为创业公司影响力不够，
跟大公司竞争天生有劣势，
熟人，社交圈内推，
才是最重要的渠道，
然后可能才是说，
我搞一批劣头，
各种招聘网站等，
当你找到好供给之后，
你一眼就知道那个人是个好人，
并且可能说那个亲朋好友们，
都给你另一件做完被调了，
反倒是你从各种渠道，
找到那个不靠谱的人，
你学花很大的力气，
很多时间去面试，
判断这个环节，
那个最最最重要的事情呢，
当然面试也很重要，
但我认为最最重要的事情是被调，
为什么呢？就是，
坦正地说，
这些大佬们，
他们的面试，
最少最少，
百分之十几二十，
都是错误了，
然后在创业的时候呢，
我认为起码呢，
可能我们看走眼三分之一，
这是最少的比例。
你觉得看走眼，
我在想啊，
因为我刚才听你在讲的时候，
我就在映射说，
你刚才讲的招聘跟，
我们去看创业者，
跟做投资其实有点像，对吧，
因为你说第一步，
扩工级其实就是sourcing，对吧，
作为投资来讲，
你一定是看得足够多了，
然后很多投资来讲，
说你看到那个对的创始人，
你就知道那个人就是好的了，
你看多了，
再来你就会有那种品味，
感觉就出来了，
但我觉得像你刚才讲的，
看走眼这个事情，
那看走眼到底因为什么？
因为我同时，
我会有一个，
跟看走眼非常反面的一个观点，
就是我会觉得你看一个人，
基本上聊过三五分钟，
你大概就知道这是一个什么人，
而且准备距离还是蛮高的。
首先我认为，
因为好人的时候，
你很容易识别出来，
那是个好人，
但如果有个不靠谱的人，
精心准备，
他很容易瞒过你，
或者可能一个五六十分的人，
或者可能一个某一方面。
有严重缺陷的人，
他经过仔细准备之后，
你可能会觉得他是七八十分，
或者你没觉察到，
他在某一方面是有缺陷的。
对,
我觉得可能像你讲的，
就是比如五六十跟七八十，
有可能会不好判断，
然后我的经验是，
九十多的人呢，
你有时候会跟，
十分二十分的人混淆，
就是都是很神奇的人，
就是那种感觉，
就是大致几点，
你无法判断，
你觉得这个人好像特别厉害，
但有可能之后，
他是一个特别SB的人，
也有可能，
就这两种人，
反而会有点像。
有些人是很难判断，
那他跟表达有点关系，
就是,
哪怕是我们在公司的时候，
你说320评估，
其实你可以发现，
哎,
可能这公司，
我们已经跟他公司一两年了，
但你会发现
320评估的差异可能很大，
所以更不用说，
我们花一两个小时，
做过面试，
去图判断经众这个人，
这其实是一个非常非常。
高难度的事情，
需要很科学的方法，
通过很多时间经营到高难，
所以我认为，
对大家现在这个阶段，
最重要是你去搞背掉，
你找他的前主管，
跟他很做过的，
靠谱的人，
一定要这个人很靠谱，
靠谱的人去搞清楚，
到底是不是他那人，
这是最重要的。
然后另外一个，
反过来的事情，
就是,
你如果周围有些靠谱的人，
想办法，
把他周围靠谱的人给弄完，
呃这么个情况，
对，这是判断这个环节，
判断这个环节呢，
主要的问题，
可能就是很多人，
做工太多了，
大家做错了方向，
然后下面是谈判这个事情，
谈判这个事情，
我认为前期是还好，
更多事情，
主要谈的是预期，
为什么这样讲呢？
就是,
今天价值创业公司，
可能有两多同学，
因为波人呢，
可能是去不了大厂，
或者不爱去大厂，
另外一波人呢，
可能就是，
不能在创业团内而来的，
但来的时候，
不是为了说，
就是心情而来的，
更多的其实是，
想做成一些很有意义的事情，
或者你需要找到那样的人，
而不是找的，
可能一定要给你纠结，
我是38,500,。
还是34,500,。
然后我建后选人，
一般可能最关键的事情是，
他三五年之前，
到底想要什么，
你能不能把那个东西给他解决了，
而剩下谈钱，
都是很好谈的事情，
其实呢，
钱这个事情，
也不用特别纠结，
我自己的看法是，
今年之后的每一天，
都是你最好招人的时候，
以后的供需会越来越紧张，
你会越来越难招人，
随着AI的发展，
所以就是，
今天你给多少钱，
都是赚的，
但你刚才讲的一个，
他三五年后，
想要什么这个点，
我的感觉是，
很多人他自己不知道，
我聊过非常多，
哪怕他已经在大厂，
已经实现财务自由的，
他可能仍然，
在自我纠结这个问题，
未来三五年我要什么东西，
然后年轻的人，
更不知道了，对吧，
口头上他会讲一些东西，
他说,
我想要的是成长，
我想要的是什么，
这其实是一个很难的面试题，
就是,
你得有这个跑根问到底，
把它真正不想要什么，
要什么，
真正帮他分析清楚，
这个是一个，
心理咨询的赛事的感觉，
对,
你要心理咨询，
知道这些规划什么都行，
你得可能跟他一起讨论清楚，
他现在到底处理什么阶段，
他未来三五年，
到底需要什么，
他什么样是开心的，
什么样是不开心的，
我经常还会问那个问题是，
在你过去的几年里边，
到底什么东西，
会让你开心，
或者最底层那个东西，
是事业上的成就感，
还是影响他人，
还是被他人认可，
还挣了点钱，还是什么，
因为尤其我们想招的一些人，
可能都是一个比较自身，
或者比较好的同学，
普通可能还加点钱，
不会让他快乐的，
你得必须得找到
最底层驱动他的那个点，
然后再结合行业，
结合他自己的情况，
他哪来他有点三文，
到底需要什么，
你的经验来看，
你都说人是想得很明白，
还是想得不明白，
大厂里面80%-90%的人，
是没想明白的，
我经常问的两个问题就是，
你为什么想离开这，
下一份工作，
你想得到什么，
解决什么问题，
就你一抛80%-90%的人，
其实就算他想了一支，
他都没想清楚这个事情，
对，我之前在极客发过一条，
我觉得非常有道理的话，
我请的就是说，
你不要因为想离开一个地方，
而去另外一个地方，
但我觉得很多人是这样的，
就是我在这边待的不舒服了，
然后那边正好有机会，
我就赶紧过去，
是的,
OK,
所以这个就是选用于地态这几块，
对吧,
这里说明提一下，
就是大家经常说自己，
尤其评读多，
对吧,
现在是给一个人，
可能两倍的薪水，
三倍的火之类的，
我往具体的一个数是多少来着，
这个是一个什么样的道理，
我们只能讨论自己的对应的那一段时间的策略，
就是,
这个人假定之前是100块钱，
然后跳跳都是去上100，
可能给100、130，
当年自己的做法，
可能是给140、150，
然后让它这个大小周，
评读多可能会更狠一些，
直接可能要170、180，
然后让它单修，
再半时间更长，
这个从实行角度来说，
肯定是划算的，
这个AI时代是否要这么搞呢，
可以值得上去，
OK,
我还讲，
从组织上，
就是你之前，
我觉得我们讨论过一些，
其他公司的一些例子，
挺好玩的，
你能不能分享一些，
因为我知道很多国内的，
不管是，
王先生、张一鸣，
他们去学习Google，
把学习Netflix，
学习Amazon,。
等等,
那你有沒有那些，
海外的一些公司的，
组织跟招聘例子，
是比较经典，
比较有意思的，
可以分享？
我们就以库共济，
这个事情为例吧，
就很多人，
其实把这个事情搞反了，
比如说，大伙就，
哎，Google那么有钱，
所以他花了很多人来做招聘，
但其实不是这样的，
其实他谷歌，
在早期的时候，
包括Opening,。
早期的时候，
有足够多的资源来搞贡献，
那到今天，
谷歌会投入好几千人的招聘团队，
其实包括自己也是，
电份器的时候，
也有几千人的招聘团队，
几千H2吗？
包括正面，
包括实习生，
包括外报，
来做招聘工作，
几千个人，
大概每年招多少人？
他不是均匀分布的，
比如说你招销售，
或者招审合，
那很好招，
但平时招联发，
那很难招，
可能说，
如果招联发的话，
我认为一个人，
我觉得一年搞个，
四十个左右的入职，
在大厂里面，
是一个比较理想的指标，
但是,
首先呢，
创业公司招人，
原本就会比大厂难，
所以我认为呢，
就指标就应该坎半，
才对,
一人招二十个人，
其次呢，
今天A&N,
我们需要的是好手，
我们不需要一些，
平平应用的人，
我自己的看法是，
如果你的H2，
一年能给你招十个好手，
可以招八个好手，
足够了，
每个月，
或者每一个半月，
能给你招一个好手，
这个H2,
太棒了，
我再补充一个问题，
我们再讲回到Google，
就是,
当一个创业公司，
在特别早期的时候，
可能他只有，
三四个人的时候，
我觉得这个时候，
他应该先招一个H2，
还是他自己，
就是最大的H2，
他应该先招一个H2，
这个时代，
会跟上个时代招聘，
有很大的不同，
这个时代sourcing工作，
我们很多时候，
应该是，
业务同学自己做，
因为这个时代，
你有了A&N，
你可以写很多的工具，
你给他PAP上爬，
你即刻上爬，
你去帮助上爬，
然后,
你可能去，
这个小红书上，
去搜热帖，
然后看下面的评论，
然后去翻这些人的主页，
你有很多很多的方式爬，
更不用说，
写个招聘网，
来爬重，
或者简历晒晒的工具了，
就是,
你写,
你找,
是最快的，
然后H2,
也没什么其他的区道，
H2人脉还不如你，
所以,
你找出来之后，
然后你让AI去判断，
或者你自己，
根据自己的喜好，
你自己摘也行，
那判断完了之后，
然后H2就联系，
H2主要承担的是，
AI和真实世界的连接工作，
去联系这个人，
就找联系方式，
对，找到联系方式联系这个人，
OK,OK,
就是做投资经理的事情，
然后你就自己做合伙人，
去做判断，
对，就是，
我自己摸索下来，
我认为这个方式最好的，
但这样的话，
一开始的时候，
对这个H2的要求，
你就没有那么高的，对吧，
也挺难的，
好爱刷很难找，
高屏这个行业，
好人没有弄得多，
OK,
你讲回来，
再把Google那个人讲完了，
嗯,
就Google有很多很有意思的点，
但可能不是，
因为当下这个阶段，
比如说，
我们可以把谷歌，
亚马逊放在一起来做对比，
这个基本上，
就是,
自己跟美团分别学习的。
对比方的对象，
就是,
谷歌,
其实是，
短业务铁，
短周期，
高码铁，
所以谷歌大概的原则，
就是我把好人，
谷歌的其实sourcing，
开始专门的sourcing team，
这个team,
并不会具体的岗位负责，
它只是说，
我带着好人了，
我还弄过来，
弄过来之后，
然后专门一个面试员，
会去面试，
面试员会，
并不带着具体的岗位去面试，
在很长的一个时间内，
只是说，
公司需要面这个人，
我来看看，
各种基本面，
看看聪明晨，
弄各种的东西，
之后呢，
让我们几个人，
背靠背面试，
让我们谷歌的招聘标准，
那就把它弄进来，
然后招聘团内，
再去跟内部看，
哎,
我们这可能有什么什么团内，
可能要和大家来看，
看这个人合不合适，
然后一跟后面人商量一下，
看我们这有8个部门，
或者10个部门，
你看这两个感兴趣，
这是谷歌的做法，
谷歌的做法，
就特别适合于，
像字节，
或者其他的一些，
这种高毛率的公司，
然后严马逊是另外一套做法，
严马逊，
那我是一个低毛率的公司，
而且我是一个，
这个长洲期慢慢变化的行业，
所以我是需要持续跌淡，
慢慢跌淡，
严马逊每团都在东间层，
招了一批很好的同学，
剩下的其实大部分呢，
可能是个行业中上水平的东西，
开过这么一个情况，
它的招聘大概的逻辑就是，
我们每年要做很重的运营计划，
花一个月、两个月，
我们把明年，
到底业务要打开什么目标，
搞清楚，
然后对应的需要多少钱，
需要多少人，
需要什么样支极的人，
然后这些人的人的成本多少钱，
通通的搞清楚，
搞清楚之后，
然后我们要开始招，
招的过程中，
也依然是被靠背面式，
我们相互之间不要受影响，
然后被靠背面式完了之后，
其实还有个，
我们叫深干圆巴里泽这个角色的人，
还有个公司内第三方，
那个比较自身的人，
然后我们大家一起坐下来，
打佩底揭开，
然后给我们一起来讨论，
这根道地腹部符合我们的要求，
并且我们还有一个要求就是，
必须是符合现有团内，
前百分之五水平的人，
他就靠这个，
在结合每年淘汰百分之十人，
现在马逊基本上每年强制淘汰的，
每年招进来的人，
是现有团内水平，
前百分之五水平的人，
然后每年再淘汰百分之十的人，
那基本上保证，
三四年，
这个团内基本上就写了一遍，
它是这样的一个逻辑，
就这两套方法，
可能都太大了，
不太适合创业公司，
但,
其中的被靠背面式，
等于一些最基础的理念，
是适合创业公司，
所以,
你觉得太AI这个时代，
包括你自己现在也在创业，
也在招人，
你觉得跟之前那些年，
你经历的，
有那些是变化的，
有那些现在当下的观点，
你其实没那么认可啊，
其实我们可以把机座跟，
利用参加来说，
因为机座的战争，
基本上已经进入淘汰赛道，
我们可以把他放一遍，
我们先不讨论这个东西，
利用它我认为，
因为刚才讨论的是几百亿美元，
可能我们现在只是一个，
几亿或者几十亿美元，
估值的公司，
可能更不需要那么多，
可能几个或者几十个人就足够了，
但是我认，
OPC是不太靠谱的，
我认为还是希望每个方向上，
大家都一两个好手，
大家一起来形成合理的，
就是的确AI今天能干增长，
能干运营，
能干很多很多的事情，
但如果每个方向有个好手，
然后带着AI一起来干，
这个公司应该能做出更伟大的成就，
我认为OPC是对这个时代和自己的浪费，
就今天最差最差也是，
PC互联网，
刚开始的时代，
如果今天我们回到90年代，
或者零几年的时候，
你还非常懂互联网，
你是有机会做社交，
做门户，
做搜索，
做很大的事情的，
没有必要去做个什么个人战，
然后说出来，
根本你的问题是啥？
就是AI时代对，
就是你实际上，
你现在自己在招人，
和在搭组织的时候，
跟之前经历的有什么不同吗？
比如你选人的标准，
可能都是一些大家都知道的一些原则，
就是选懂AI的人，
然后团内比较精干，
没有什么特殊的东西，
但只不过说，
据我自己所观察，
很多创业公司执行得也不是特别的好，
就很多创业公司招的一些人，
他都不能百分百AI Coding，
我不确定为什么要招，
你觉得，
你现在招的每一个人都必须是会AI Coding，
他本来自带这个能力，
如果是程序员的话，一定是百分百，
程序员肯定是，
对，然后如果其他模块呢，最好是，
就是这个是一个当下的硬条件，
对，当下的硬条件，
这个其实本质，
今天我们没讨论到这个问题，
就是在组织到底该怎么把这些人组织起来，
刚才我们其实讨论的是单个人，
我们怎么去选用余力碳，
我自己的体感是，
第一个，因为没有了产品，
前端，后端，测试，算法，
这样的区分，
所以会导致一个好处是，
你可以按照业务模块区分，
这个人把从产品到测试全搞了，
协作沟通会非常非常的少，
第二个事情是，
对于很多非产业的团队来说，
比如说销售，比如说增长，
或者是任何各种各样的团队，
如果他们会变成，
公司的效率会完全不一样，
首先那个团队的，
本身的效率就会可能翻5倍、10倍，
其次是，
你不再需要给他们找产业团队，
或者你可能产业团队把一些基建给他继好，
这个是一个非常巨大的工作模式的改变，
公司的运软节奏也会完全不一样，
然后刚才我们有提到，
比如说自己也是一种组织形态，
对应他的不同的业务模式，
然后每团可能也是一种，
那世界上的这种业务形式跟组织形式对应的，
是能穷进的，
比如说那几大类，
如果这个人他是一个出生公司创始人，
他该怎么样去参考选择和学习自己的合适的组织，
可能可以划个组标准，不一定可以穷进，
如果按照刚才那个业务链条长短，
毛利率高低iPhone的话，
那可能是个三位的组标准，
比如说有那些是比较典型的对应的，
然后一级他对应的组织形式是什么的，
就谷歌字节肯定是属于刚才说的那一头，
然后每台亚马逊以及很多Engine的公司，
有属于另外一头，
然后像我们在做招聘嘛，
招聘可能就属于业务周期，
还算短，但链条中间，然后毛利率中间适应。
所以你们应该对应的是什么样的组织？
如果一定要对比他，
可能是上个时代的大型SARS公司，
或者一些中等的品牌型公司。
所以你觉得现在的当时移动互联网那一波的时候，
你看张一鸣，
其实他虽然之前参加过一些创业公司的项目，
但其实他相对还是比较注定的嘛，
对吧，在创业的时候，
王星应该是比张一鸣更Singer一点，
但是在创业头那时候，
前面已经有些更成功的创业的经验了。
但那一波反正就是有很猪腻的人，
或者说刚在大厂工作个两三年的人出来创业，
最后做得也还行，
当然确实少，
但在今天你觉得跟当时会有什么区别吗？
我说过可能说跟商主流不太一样，
我知道很多那个VC都拖了零零后，
或者非常爱拖零零后，
肯定不爱拖我们这种四十二岁的，
我会有一个不太一样的看法就是，
我说商业竞争是一个非常非常残酷的事情，
他在每个赛道里面，
就流出来的时间中口气，
往常常说最多两年，
我挡了手可能就半年一年，
然后这个CEO一号位和他所在的整个团队，
他需要能够快速构建起，
融资,
摸清楚方向，
建好团队的能力，
这其实非常难的，
这对零零后其实不公平的，
他毕竟刚出校门没几年，
他也不认识几个人，
别的不说，
他能够在每个方向传一个好手吗？
其实挺难的，
然后他后面可能要面临。
很激烈的，
融资的时候各种各样恶心的事情，
不合理的条款，合理的条款，
然后或者被忽悠了，
可能要面临竞争那一手合法的，
不合法的竞争，
业务院长好的时候，
可能还会面临各种各样的技术上的问题，
业务院长不好的时候，
可能还有如何能够。
搭着兄弟们一起扛过来，
我相信零零后，
在四五年后那一波，
因为我认为这一波是很长的，
那个主席应该会不断的有一波一波的，
在四五年后那一波，
经历了这一波的折腾之后，
他应该能做出来很好的事情，
但是未来的两三年，
在这一波里面，
我觉得零零后，
就跟九零后，九五后打，
它是不公平的。
我说还是需要这波创始人，
尤其是这一波是从。
二年十一月三十号开始的，
到现在已经三年半的时间了，
需要这个创始人
已经在一些方向上。
摸索得七七八八了，
且传那个还不错的传内，
且撞得到钱，
这很现实的。
但我在想，
就比如说，
我们还是讲，
不管自己还没团里面，
你刚说大家是靠打仗起来的，
那打仗战场里面，
其实大家不会分年龄的，
可能是同时的，
比如说有零零后，
有九零后，
有八零后，
甚至有七零后，
那里面就是，
应该是会有一个零零后，
突然脱颖而出，
说他就是，
成长特别快，
然后升之特别快，
然后他之后，
比如说他在自己，
他干到了零零后，
现在应该也没有四缸一吧，
那个有点夸张，是吧？
对，反正就是，
你大概理解我意思，
就是年轻的距离。
不畏你意思，
但是做一号为何，
那个做在里面可能，
说负责增长，
或者负责研发是两码事情，
就是,
你如果跟着今天的张一鸣干，
说这个研发感到特别好，
那这个我信，
但是说你说，
定逼了一个零零后，
在个竞争积累的赛道上，
其中有几个团队，
已经传了一个很好的团队了，
然后也融了很多钱，
然后解他们竞争经验，
白的黑的手段都会，
这边可能是我们钢琴少门的一群人，
团队还没传起，跟他打，
那就是吃亏的。
或者在这个历史上，
没有见过可能说，
在大的赛道里面，
占大搞成功的。
我觉得这儿，
正好可以聊一些，
投资人喜欢给壮神大的标签，
我觉得跟你刚才讲的，
有点类似，
就是工作时间长的，
有资源的人呢，
大家容易会觉得这个人，
比如油，
这个人呢，
他是什么高管气质，
反而不落地，
可能创新速度不够快，
就会有这些点。
比如你刚才说那个，
我就想到说，
有的人他可能是有资源，
但是因为他有这些资源，
他特别懂那个规则，
所以他反而不敢去打爆规则，
反而年轻人呢，
他更觉得，
你可以讲他是无知者无味，
就是干就是上，
然后可能谁就撞到了，
然后他就起来了。
你找到那些90后，
80后里面纯粹的人，
他们是真的想改这个行业的，
并且他们还在一线。
对，我特别喜欢你那个词，
我觉得纯粹很重要，
对吧?
就我去总结，
就说这个人得成熟，
但是同时又有少年感。
是的。
所以最后再聊一下你自己，
现在在做的事情，
你现在是自己，
也在做AI的创业嘛，对吧？
对，是的。
你给大家简单介绍一下，
你现在在做的事情吗？
我认为招聘工作肯定会AI化，
招聘本质上是一个。
供需两端匹配的事情，
目前的匹配效率，
所以各个招人方，
我想大家非常有体感，
我认为这个工作一定会被AI化掉，
AI应该会大幅提升这个。
供需匹配的效率，
且在里边尽量减少人的存在，
帮助好的业务主管。
和招聘同学提效很多位，
就是第一点，
第二点是招聘市场，
尤其是蓝领招聘市场，
除了效率问题外，
还存在很严重的欺骗问题，
中国的工人，
服务员等蓝领求职者，
99%都被骗过，
我们希望我们这一代人。
帮中国几亿求职者，
少被骗，
更快找到合适的工作，
多赚点钱，
很朴素的愿景。
所以你们现在自己也在招人吧，对吧？
对,
如果是你在创业同学，
欢迎大家一起来交流这个组织建设，
然后想加入创业公司的同学，
如果说你现在是技术卫园的同学，
你现在用超过两个max的套餐，
非技术同学你在搞AI编程，
然后都欢迎大家交流认识一下，
不管是来我这儿，
或者是说，
我也可以推荐一些其他更好回的创业公司，
欢迎大家认识认识。
然后后面，
我们这次不课以后，
就有一个活动，
尤其欢迎AI相关的创业者参与吧。
小康可能当天可以更具体的来完整的讲一下这套东西。
对，欢迎大家一起来探讨摩托，
就是AI时代的组织模式，
我理解也会有很大的差异，
比如说刚才我们讨论的那个协作的问题，
在AI时代协作会简单很多。
除此之外，
这些其他东西，
大家可以一起来探讨它。
OK,好呀,
那我们就期待跟大家后面，
可能现下活动的时候再见。
谢谢去看，
欢迎大家多招了，
欢迎大家观众识谈的。